on Tuesday prince and princess privacy
Harry and Meghan Markle claimed to have
been involved in a quote near
catastrophic car chase at the hands of a
ring of Highly aggressive Paparazzi a
quote Relentless Pursuit lasting over
two hours resulting in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers wow quite the story I was just
waiting for the part where Megan held
onto her Subway sandwich while the
Nigerian white supremacist Paparazzi
told her that Manhattan is Naga country
and I was not
the only person perhaps to be skeptical
of the story for starters the story
resembled the car chase that ended with
the death of Harry's mother Diana almost
perfectly few other facts that raised
some doubts about the markle's claims
include the testimony of the NYPD which
observed that the couple quote arrived
at their destination and there were no
reported collisions summonses injuries
or arrests as well as the testimony of
the cabbie who said quote I never felt
like I was in danger it wasn't like a
car chase in a movie as well as the fact
that it's New York City
one of the most congested places on
Earth where it is not possible to have a
two hour or even a two-minute car chase
because the traffic is always so bad
even the liberal mayor of New York was
not buying it I would find it hard to
believe that there was a two-hour
high-speed chase that would be finding
hard to believe but we will find out the
exact duration of it
it's a very diplomatic way of saying
it's just total BS and it's not just the
markles okay if it were just the markers
I'd let it go we wouldn't open the show
this way but it's not just the markles
it's the markles
and the media
and the FBI
and pretty much the whole regime
we are ruled by a bunch of BS artists
that is the inevitable consequence of a
culture that shirks Duty and favors
fantasy and rejects the very notion of
truth right now go to genucel.com
Knowles did you know our friends over
Virginia cell have upgraded their most
popular package to feature their top
selling deep firming vitamin C serum
plus Ultra retinol moisturizer with
natural retinol alternative right now
you can take advantage of this limited
time package upgrade for 70 percent off
why waste time and money to go get work
done on your face when you can get
geniusl skin care shipped right to your
door here is a geniusell.com review from
Robert in blessing Texas quote I
purchased geniusell as a gift for my
girlfriend she said she saw the results
so fast her skin is noticeably softer
and smoother I can see and feel the
difference too she was already beautiful
and geniusell has made her more
beautiful and I'll tell you I assumed
genius I figured it was just for the
girls right no it turns out actually
guys tend to use it even more than women
too we just don't like to admit it great
company fabulous product and the founder
is a great guy Coptic Christian from
Egypt who came over here for the
American dream go to genucel.com Knowles
try geniusell's most popular package for
seventy percent off featuring both
genusel's Ultra retinol and genocel's
Firming Serum get a complimentary Spa
Essentials box with every package order
plus free upgrade to priority shipping
that is geniusell.com Knowles
geniusell.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s right right now head on
over to goodranchers.com use promo code
Knowles Memorial Day is a time to honor
and remember our brave service men and
women who made the ultimate sacrifice
for our country it is also a time to
come together as a nation gather with
loved ones and enjoy some mouth-watering
meals what better way to do that than
with premium 100 American Mead from good
ranchers good ranchers is not like the
other meat delivery companies that
import a majority of their products they
are compassionate about delivering the
finest 100 American meat right to your
doorstep here's something special good
ranchers proudly offers a 10 discount to
all past and present service members as
a way of saying thank you for your
service but that's not it in honor of
Memorial Day good ranchers is giving our
listeners an exclusive opportunity when
you use coded Knolls kwles you can save
up to 25 percent site-wide from tender
steaks to succulent chicken
goodranchors.com has it all I'm on the
road right now one of the few things to
really bug me is I don't get my good
ranchers as regularly as I am able to at
home it's the meat is just unbelievable
fire up the grill on Memorial day with
your family and friends knowing that the
meat you're enjoying is not only of the
highest quality but also supports
American Ranchers go to goodranchers.com
today use code Knolls Canada wles to
save up to 25 site wide the more you
stock up on the more you will save
during the Memorial Day sale codenols
goodranchors.com good ranchers American
Meat delivered did you feel it
did the wind blow through your hair as
we slid further down that slippery slope
because you can go over to the
chalkboard you can put down another
correct prediction for the social
conservatives
we've slid further down the slippery
slope I think the score right now is 10
bazillion to zero in terms of
predictions but it doesn't really matter
because the social conservatives
continue to be right and the Liberals
continue to get whatever they want this
time on
polygamy and polyamory remember when the
conservatives those crazy fuddy duddy
neurotic conservatives
they said when the libs were trying to
redefine marriage that if we redefine
marriage to include
Two Men and two women
that pretty soon we're going to redefine
marriage to include polygamy and
polyamory and it's going to be not just
one man and another man but one man and
three women and two billy goats and a
sheep and guess what happened that's
exactly what happened from The New York
Times quote
interested in polyamory check out these
places
subheader laws granting rights to people
in polyamorous relationships are being
recognized in more cities now to be
clear this isn't polygamy yet
this isn't redefining marriage yet this
is the first step this is the civil
unions of
orgies
okay the the
first step is we're just going to give
some rights so what does it matter Love
Is Love who cares why are you such a
fuddy daddy we're not redefining
marriage to include polygamy okay you
crazy person
and then
within a matter of years at most we're
going to start seeing these these new
rights that we're extending to some
people who are just a little bit
different that's going to be extended to
redefining marriage if it hasn't been
totally abolished already
article Jace Knight had heard about
Somerville Massachusetts while working
on a PhD at the University of Alabama in
2020.
this small City had recently passed a
law granting domestic partnership rights
like the ability to receive employment
benefits or make hospital visits to
people in polyamorous relationships mix
night that's what they do now instead of
Mr and Miss and Mrs even the feminist
Miz
now the people who are confused about
their sex they do MX period mix night
who is non-binary and has been
non-monogamous since 2014 was impressed
in late March Somerville passed two more
laws extending the rights of
non-monogamous residents this time
Banning discrimination on the basis of
family or relationship structure in City
employment and housing similar ordinance
focused on housing is currently being
discussed in Somerville City and that's
because mix night
has two partners and a partner of one of
those partners and the you get the point
there are a bunch of other people like
this a bunch of other towns doing this
it's always the same script so we just
want to visit people in the hospital you
know you can change Hospital rules right
you don't need to fundamentally redefine
marriage and man and woman you can you
can just change visitation rules within
the hospitals themselves well we and we
want certain non-discrimination rights I
don't know if you're a complete
degenerate who has orgies all the time
and is living in this bizarre
Arrangement where no one knows anybody's
sex and you're all doing weird stuff all
the time with multiple people I I feel I
should be able to discriminate against
you
discriminate meaning distinguish from
one thing to another if I got two
candidates for a job thank goodness I'm
not in the position to hire anybody or
the nlrb would probably be on my back
already before the end of this show but
if I were I'm just saying this
hypothetically in principle if I were
going to hire somebody
and I wanted to hire I don't know a guy
to look after my house
someone to look after my kids let's say
especially but let's say just someone to
look after my property
and I had two choices I had a guy who
was an upright Family Man married took
care of his responsibilities you know
went to church on Sunday said just a
good a good guy all around and then I've
got this other guy who doesn't know that
he's a guy and who's constantly engaging
in weird bacchanals and orgies and is
just so hyper focused on sex and porn
and obscenity that's the only thing that
goes between one ear and the other
that's basically melted his brain which
person do you think is going to be more
responsible
to do the job which person is going to
have a better grasp on reality and
morality and the way that people are
supposed to behave but according to
Somerville Massachusetts you're not
you're not allowed to even perceive that
distinction
haven't we gone a little bit far
wouldn't you say there's a little bit of
drift here from hey don't unjustly
discriminate against the El Salvadoran
over the Italian or something versus hey
don't discriminate between
people who can't even understand the
difference between men and women to say
nothing of the fundamental political
structure if you cannot
discriminate
on the basis of
what people think a family is then what
you're saying is you can't discriminate
on the on the fundamental political
structure because that's the basic
political unit
but the libs are discriminating
of course the libs are discriminating if
you think that marriage is and family is
what it always has been
you're out man your views are not
accepted anymore
you will be discriminated against in the
culture and through the law
and what will be discriminated for is
going to be mix night with his 17
partners and their 22 partners
and the billy goat not good boy oh boy
that was a great clip if you want all
the clips and the interviews and the yes
or no game and the full show you got to
subscribe ring the bell we'll see you
next time